die fed definierung auf sf mit dieser
swiss re group
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die welt wandelt sich auch jene der
winzer für manche schweizer weinbauern
steht die zukunft auf dem spiel
in genf wo daniel mehr nur gegen den rat
seines vaters ins geschäft einsteigen
will
er sagte mir ganz klar mach was anderes
wer das mit leidenschaft macht opfert
leicht sein ganzes leben dafür
[Musik]
im loro piana schon dem betrieb seinem
sohn brasil übergeben hat es ist genauso
halten mit seinen kindern zu arbeiten
wie mit seinen vater jetzt habe ich das
sagen aber sicher müssen wir wachsen
[Musik]
im tessin oder das riesige weingut
tamburini nach generationen der
männerherrschaft nun von dieser jungen
frau valentina geleitet wird
als frau hat man es in diesem metier
nicht leicht es ist nach wie vor eine
männerdomäne
[Musik]
in graubünden wo ihr im grünen felder
gegen den willen ihrer kinder das bio
zertifikat anstrengend
auf dem weg hoch zum weingut denke ich
mir immer wunderschön aber stark
gefährdet
und im wallis wo marion brasch mit aller
kraft eines der vorzeige güter führt
sie ist die seele des weinguts beton
die winzerinnen der berggipfel die einen
nachfolger sucht für diese fünf
winzerinnen und winzer ist der
jahresverlauf voller ungewissheit vier
jahreszeiten
[Musik]
es ist winter in der schweiz auch im
genfer weinland liegt schnee zeit für
reparaturen in der scheune treffen die
lueg und damian marron vater und sohn
der dritten winzer generation
kannst du das ding mal stützen
oder sollen wir nachher aber nicht unter
oder wir schmeißen direkt eine mutter an
wir nehmen einlagern bohren durch wir
nehmen ein lager und schweißen direkt
darunter eine mutter an
wir machen die eröffnung größer
schweißen die mutter an und drehen das
ding so klappt ist pragmatisch mit 19
schlosser die mechaniker ausbildung ab
und ich fragte ihn was wirst du jetzt
tun würde bis zu autos reparieren
er schaute mich völlig perplex an und
sagte nein nein ich will doch hier
arbeiten
[Applaus]
ich kam zurück und wollte hier als
winzer einsteigen
aber er sagte klipp und klar ich solle
mir eine andere arbeit suchen er hatte
sich schon immer gedanken darüber
gemacht er wollte nicht dass ich mit 60
mal so kaputt und verbraucht bin wie er
das wetter hat man dauernd im auge mein
vater beobachtete ästhetik er starb am
15 juli 2016 mit 94 jahren eines
natürlichen todes
am tag zuvor hatte er mich noch gefragt
wie geht es den reben irgend welche
krankheiten wie machen sich die trauben
wie diesen wie das so läuft das und da
wollte ich es erfahre
und trotzdem hat sich daniel dafür
entschieden
seit einigen jahren führte den betrieb
und dieses jahr ist wegweisend also wir
schneiden die reben und du kümmerst dich
um die lehrlinge
ja klar auch pierre übergibt an seinen
sohn brasil soll sich nun um alles
kümmern
der boden ist knapp im lavaux sie haben
nur drei hektaren zur verfügung
es ist genauso heikel mit seinen kindern
zu arbeiten wie mit seinem vater
es kommt auf das gleiche raus der
weinbau hat sich ständig
weiterentwickelt und zwar in praktisch
allen ländern wo wein angebaut wird
und eines tages sagte ich habe sagte ich
gehe weg
ich schlug vor dass wir ein zwei jahre
zusammenarbeiten und ich ihm dann das
ruder überlassen würde
die bringt solch gute frische
temperaturen
was für ein glück 1990 war es ende
februar sehr warm für die jahreszeit das
ist nie gut
die knospen brachen ende märz zu früh
auf und wir mussten gespannt bis zum
ersten mai warten weil bis dann einfach
ein frost risiko besteht ja und letztes
jahr war es eiskalt
mein vater ist ein wandelndes klima
lexikon
seine meinung ist immer interessant er
sagt dinge wie es ist 20 grad warm
es hat 30 millimeter geregnet das ist
nicht gut für uns
egal was du auch tust solche aussagen
sind wichtig weil man sich dadurch
vieles ersparen wir tragen die last der
jahre mit das heißt wir haben
lebenserfahrung
man kann nicht einfach sagen ich
überlasse ihr den betrieb hier meine
kundenliste ich bin dann mal weg so geht
das nicht
eine betriebsübergabe muss doch richtig
begleitet werden damit das danach folge
leicht
den eigenen stil zu entwickeln ohne die
tradition zu verbessern
darum geht es jetzt für basel
[Musik]
an diesem tag im februar besuchen david
und gerne ihre großmutter marion auf
ihrem weingut bildung auf 900 metern
höhe oberhalb von vieh nur diese
seilbahn führt hier hoch
[Applaus]
wir gehen raus david weißt du wie alt
diese reben sind sie waren schon 1971
als oberzicke das weingut bedurfte als
ich hierher kam versprach mir sagt dass
ich mein flöten studium weitermachen
könne
aber bildung hat gesiegt und ich glaube
das studium auf wenigstens habe ich
meine drei töchter beeinflussen kann
sie sind alle musikerinnen geworden und
nicht winzerinnen beim rebschnitt muss
das auge hier vorne sein siehst du es
müssen zwei augen seien hier hinten ist
1&1 hier hakt das lassen und hier
schneiden
nein vor der wunde muss es sein dann
nimmst du das so kommen zwei raus egal
wenn es kleiner ist als das andere
siehst du so peters das ist der walliser
im schnitt konnten ihren beruf frei
wählen
sie helfen mir aber so gut sie kann weil
ich ihnen gesagt habe wenn beton
bestehen bleiben soll
schaffe ich das nicht allein bist du
wieder runter dann musst du dort sein
ich treffe meine freunde um halb zwei du
wolltest doch zur fasnacht aber erst
gibt es etwas zu essen
david und galliani müssen runter zur
fasnacht aber mit leerem magen lässt sie
sie natürlich nicht gehen
wollt ihr euch nicht setzen
lauda mit viel spaß an der fasnacht
danke für den besuch danke
guten appetit danke für das essen als
david auch einen tisch im restaurant
worden
schmeckt lecker und seit schön brav
david keine hundekacke in briefkästen
schmeißen können
[Musik]
ohne chichi der vor 18 monaten starb
stellt sich die frage der nachfolge
marion brasch und ihren zwei
angestellten steht ein übergangsjahr
bevor
[Musik]
immer durch die rebberge bis ans andere
ende der schweiz sanken wir in
graubünden hierfür tiere in den betrieb
ihr sohn johannes steckt mitten zwischen
zwei praktika im ausland
denn der kunde ein mache das man im
norden noch monate verlängern und den
leuten wichtig aber es ist wirklich toll
wollen die ihnen das macht spaß und es
ist deshalb besonders aber was willst du
machen
stock abstand bei den grünen fehlers
zeigt man noch charakter
man hält zusammen auch wenn man nicht
immer gleicher meinung ist er in will
dieses jahr das bio zertifikat haben was
nicht bei allen in der familie ankommt
bewirtschaften biologisch aber nicht
zertifiziert willi finde große sache
biologischer anbau sind zum teil bis
frau gehörte goldmann man sich
hinterfragen ob das denn so viel sinn
macht wirklich zum konventioneller die
finden wenn man bio als marketing
missbraucht dann kann man seine ziele
ich bin heilig halbe zurück das ist
schluss
bio und eine faire geste für sich
gemacht haben fragen zu schutz und
irgendwas er macht das wie wichtig man
kann einem radfahrer
[Musik]
im tessin steckt das bekannte weingut
tamburini auch in einem übergang von
vater zu tochter valentina
es kommt mir vor als wäre ich schon 14
jahre im geschäft nicht erst 4 zu sehen
zu hören und lernen sagt mein vater
immer aber er macht mir keine
vorschriften
ich hab sowieso meinen eigenen willen
dennoch respektiere ich was er über die
jahre aufgebaut und mir beigebracht hat
hier hat valentina ihren ersten weißwein
gemacht ihren ersten eigenen jahrgang
aus trauben von dieser parzelle mit
dabei ist ihr chef ökonom
ich mach nur er der faust zugeschlagen
wir nehmen alles weg das war der frost
im letzten jahr
wir müssen etwas zurück schneider
bereits etikettiert ja ich kontrolliere
danke an alle unternehmer sagt das
etikett sei falsch
ich muss es kontrollieren es war ja
insgesamt mir leid kein problem alles
klar
nur das problem mit dem etikett hat
vorrang
die reben werden später geschnitten
valentina muss schnell zum drucker
hier 12 6 das war der kredit 2013 13.3
der kredit 2015 und 13 6 der wifi 2017
dann stimmt ja nein sie haben gradation
12 6 gedruckt dann ist es ihr fehler
[Musik]
guten tag tamburini am apparat
ich hatte ihnen eines mit 12 6 gegeben
wie kann das passieren credit 2015
müsste 13.6 gedruckt werden
ich habe so viel im kopf da kann ich
mich nicht an alle details erinnern
ich weiß nicht ob ich heute nacht
schlafen kann
in riva erholen sich die reben während
die traubenernte des vergangenen
herbstes verarbeitet wird
brazil und sein vater filtrieren den
wein und verleihen ihm so seinen
charakter die filtration ist eine heikle
sache da ist ziemlich viel bodensatz im
tank wir müssen aufpassen dass da fehlt
da nicht verstopft es darf keine luft
rein
es darf nicht überlaufen und so weiter
all diese details sind wichtig der tank
moschee ist fertig wir machen mit dem
tanken und erweitern da ist zwei sind
machen wir jetzt die assange also der
hier und der dort um tank 14
[Applaus]
wenn man 35 jahre lang der chef war dann
ist man einfach der chef
wenn man sagen muss mach was du willst
mir egal wenn du meinst kein problem
dann wird's kompliziert dann muss man
seine schnauze erhalten
aber das ist normal so läuft es halt
schön wenn man sich einigen
brazil packt an während er sich anderen
dingen widmet er ist vizepräsident der
fed definierung und hier unterwegs zu
einer vorbereitungssitzung in w w
[Musik]
valentina sucht eine lösung für das
etikett wie eben tag ist der vater
claudio im büro das übliche
nebeneinander mit dem senior chef
[Musik]
lasst uns findest du die lösung gut
kannst du mir einen gefallen tun wurde
könntest du petit nie fragen ob es so
geht
ich möchte die flaschen nicht mehr
bewegen
sie sollen hier kommen und das problem
lösen konnte letzte nacht nicht schlafen
also noch
im weinkeller unter dem büro greift die
letztjährige merlot ernte in
eichenfässern heran
es wird über den werdenden wein
diskutiert das ist dasselbe holz wie bei
der ersten probe
das riecht man immer noch der gleiche
der gleiche aber er ist schon rund und
weich ja sehr intensiv als frau hat man
es in diesem metier nicht leicht es ist
nach wie vor eine männerdomäne
[Applaus]
was frauen sagen mag weniger gewicht
haben
aber wir müssen unsere meinung äußern
und auch zuhören können und uns ständig
weiterentwickeln
strategiesitzung der winzer bruderschaft
es geht um die finanzen der fed
definierung fakt ist dass unser
gesamtbudget heute bei 125 millionen
steht
man kann es drehen und wenden wie man
will aber 100 dürfen wir nicht
übersteigen
wir haben alle möglichkeiten
ausgeschöpft wenn wir von 100 millionen
ausgeben
dann werden die eintrittspreise durch
das budget das heißt die anzahl
vorstellung bestimmt mit den aktuellen
preisen und weil vollem haus brauchen
wir 24 vorstellungen
es liegen bereits sieben einsprachen und
die gemeinde und die stadt wäre
verlangen von uns die pläne aus zu
schreiben was es in der schweiz noch nie
gegeben hat
wir sollten die gemeinde dazu bringen
eine öffentliche sitzung einzuberufen
bei der wir der allgemeinheit und den
gegnern alles vorstellen können so
möchte eine sitzung mit entgegnen und
der allgemeinheit
ich würde lieber nur die gegner und die
gemeindevertreter treffen und mehr nicht
sonst verzetteln wir uns und finden
keine lösung finde ich auch
einverstanden
ja aber dann müsst ihr hingehen ihr
kennt das künstlerische programm und
könnt das fest ins richtige licht rücken
das kann nicht irgendjemand tun nicht
einmalig ach was
es können 23 freiwillige dabei sein die
eine ahnung von der geschichte haben
aber an der spitze müssen die stehen die
sich gut auskennen
abgemacht pierre wird das in die hand
nehmen
[Musik]
ihre insel der glückseligkeit verlässt
marion brasch selten aber heute abend
nimmt sie an einer öffentlichen
weinprobe mit einer alten freundin teil
der bekannten winzerin marie theres apa
dieser abend des 2 grund damm gewidmet
die sie wohl alle kennen nämlich marion
brasch und marie teresa park auf dem weg
hoch zum weingut denke ich mir immer
wunderschön aber stark gefährdet um das
zu verstehen muss man marion besuchen
marion die das mit ihrem mann junkie
gemacht hat der vor zwei jahren
gestorben ist oder sind schon drei am 10
juni 16 er hatte immer einen trick auf
lager
er hat dem walliser weinbau unglaublich
viel gebracht
und maria und er haben begonnen zu dem
gemacht was es heute ist
ich bin voll motiviert ich versuche
mario dazu zu bringen das weingut zu
erhalten
manchmal sieht man den wahren wert der
dinge nicht und sagt sich nein es ist
mir zu viel
aber im grunde genommen wird man davon
getragen
ich bin überzeugt marion ist die seele
des weinguts beton
[Musik]
in jenins bekommt ihren besuch von ihren
zwei kindern sohn johannes und tochter
europa finden dann 64 vor dem bio winzer
wirklich sicher ob das kritisch will
arminen am eine genau ist es nicht
möglich logisch und der frage was jetzt
wichtig ist es jetzt schwefel und kupfer
spritzig oder ökologisch aber minimal -
fahrrad und traktoren sowie das spritzen
von schwefel und kupfer sind aus
schwermetallen und schwermetall einfach
so in den boden für das umfeld auch
nicht so oft und so wird man also ich
muss das erinnert sich es war ja gemacht
berlin ihr selber will wenn er natürlich
werde
pc-ware richtlinie oder seit das ist
noch luft schweben es geht frau sei
rechtlich das ist einmalig in certi über
mit mail marketing oder einfach
konzepten zur gesundheit so sachen natur
abstimmen und so wie abbott aber die
ideen der sie dann zu marketing des
ganzen bio labels und bürger nahm ich
lebe und überhaupt ist einfach
schwachsinn und dennoch versuchte ihren
das zertifikat zu bekommen
dafür muss sie die zuständigen behörden
überzeugen was im vergleich zu ihren
kindern einfach erscheint
[Musik]
in genf damian die konsequenteste bio
art umsetzen den biodynamischen weinbau
[Musik]
dafür besuchte die schule in marseille
wir behandeln die mikrobiologie der
weine die kenntnis der mikroorganismen
der weine mittels mikrobiologische
analysen
wir werden versuchen alle eigenschaften
der trauben im rahmen der infizierung zu
bestimmen und möglichst wenige zusätze
zu verwenden insbesondere sollte als ich
zurückkam um hier zu arbeiten drängte er
darauf von all diesen herbiziden
loszukommen
man sieht es unter dem mikroskop
alles was wir in den rebbergen tun ist
darauf ausgerichtet noch bessere weine
zu machen die frage des zertifikates
stellt sich vermutlich erst wenn man
sich gegenüber den kunden rechtfertigen
muss wenn man mal auf dieser chemischen
substanzen verzichtet dann stellt man
fest dass die reden wie gewünscht
reagieren und das ermutigt einen auf
diesem weg weiter zu arbeiten so stellt
sich automatisch ein interesse am
biodynamischen anbau ein
der biodynamischen anbau ist ein
ganzheitlicher natur freundlicher ansatz
der in bildung schon vor 50 jahren
pionierhaft angewandt wurde
[Musik]
für den biodynamischen anbau braucht man
spezifische sachkenntnis mario mail
diesen beschwerlichen weg gehen selber
es fließt nichts muss das höher oder
tiefer stehen
hier fließt haben wir nur einen
zerstäuber ja der andere geht nicht nein
[Musik]
öffnest du du musst ihn ist es
verschmutzt ich verstehe dich nicht
verschmutzt ist viel mehr drin
heute geht alles schief der montagmorgen
ist immer hart
wir machen die erste bio dynamische
behandlung dieses jahres und unserer
arbeit denn viele der alles weiß und
alles kennt ist krank also müssen wir
klarkommen so gut es eben geht
der letzte tropfen
wir hatten schachtelhalm extrakt gemacht
wir lassen ihn seit letztem samstag
ziehen und bei den heute zur
verhinderung von pilzkrankheiten aus
im bio dynamischen landbau wird eine
pflanze als ein auf dem kopf stehender
mensch betrachtet das heißt die wurzeln
sind der kopf
[Musik]
die pflanze sucht über die wurzeln was
die mikroorganismen zubereitet haben
mit roundup oder anderen starken
herbiziden töten wir die mikroorganismen
ab wir töten genau jene stoffe ab die
unsere helfer sind das sollten wir nicht
tun
[Musik]
das heer so einschlagen und dann leicht
fallend hinaus letzte vorbereitungen vor
der präsentation ihres neuen weißweins
soll ich dieses zertifikat zwischen die
flaschen oder gleich zuoberst einstecken
zuoberst oder es war so der
alkoholgehalt stimmte nicht wir mussten
ihn an jeder flasche korrigieren musste
das von hand machen
man sieht es ohnehin zu schauen
aber das fällt doch überhaupt nicht auf
die 500 flaschen sind so und 500 korrekt
ein guter kompromiss
der letzte und nun muss noch eine
würdige ansprache her noch guten tag
liebe gäste willkommen im saal reise der
sinne
willkommen zur dritten ausgabe der wien
easy x unserer großen frühlings
weinprobe vor ein paar jahren war es nur
eine idee eine sehnsucht ich habe schon
herzklopfen
so geht das nicht weil china heute ist
das projekt realität
wir haben eine produktlinie nein das
gefällt mir nicht
heute ist das projekt realität
dort oben ja bei dir oh ja
sie war es gut okay du hast empanadas
gemacht ich bin dabei super hilfst du
mir klar
nach seinen matte gerne wie war dein tag
gut
großartig
brazil und seine frau nadja haben
freunde in ihren privaten weinkeller
eingeladen
die argentinierin hat ja hat sich
schnell an das dorfleben im labor
gewöhnt es war sehr gut du hast heute
wohl kunden gewonnen
so jetzt der höhepunkte einmal weg auf
diesem weingut yaman west habe ich
gearbeitet
denn gab es zur hochzeit weißt du noch
ja den haben wir gesungen getrunken
[Gelächter]
mein bruder arbeitet auf dem gute wines
of mendoza in argentinien und brasilien
auf diamant ist bei der weinlese dabei
als er zum ersten mal in argentinien war
es war sehr schöner ist brasil und ich
uns 2012 in argentinien begegnete er kam
aber nicht zu mehr um sich zu
verabschieden und so wusste ich nicht ob
wir uns wieder sehen würden
das war sehr traurig er hinterließ mir
aber einen brief und eine flasche wein
von dem weingut auf dem er gearbeitet
hatte also diamandis seither erinnern
wir uns jedes mal an unsere erste
begegnung wenn wir einen wein von dort
trinken
ja eine schöne erinnerung das ist
traubenmost direkt nach der weinlese ist
das ein orange wein oder naturrein ein
natur weil der so heißt weil keine
zusätze oder sulfide drin sind sind
vitamine drin da sind sicher vitamine
drin
außerdem finde ich den ansatz dieses
winters interessant aber das zu zweit
trinken zu müssen ist eine qual
[Gelächter]
wir gehen grundsätzlich so biologisch
wie möglich vor
aber es gibt klimatisch sehr ungünstiger
jahre in denen die reben anfällig für
kryptographische krankheiten wie
falschen oder echten mehltau sind und
die chemischen substanzen zur bekämpfung
dieser parasiten sind halt sehr wirksam
man kann es so sehen
ich bin nicht der patient der mit einem
husten zum arzt geht und sagt gut ich
muss wohl eine art bronchitis haben aber
antibiotika kommen nicht in frage so bin
ich nicht
hallo meine liebe schön dich zu sehen
das ist meine mutter guten tag freut
mich valentina tamburin o
guten tag und willkommen zur dritten
ausgabe der minis immer unserer großen
frühlings weinprobe vor ein paar jahren
war es nur eine idee eine sehnsucht
heute ist das projekt realität die
valentina wein kollektion der neue
weißwein erhält den namen wie und das
ist kein zufall mit meinem wie möchte
ich diesmal die forschung im bereich der
seltenen krankheiten unterstützen
im gedenken an eine für mich sehr
bedeutende personen nämlich meine liebe
schwester alice die uns von ihrer wolke
aus beobachtet und mir die kraft gibt
meine träume zu verwirklichen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin sehr zufrieden es ist wie eine
geburt die geburt meines ersten weine
ich bin glücklich valentina ist bei
allen gut angekommen
mit einer ausnahme hast du meine wie die
präsentation gesehen
nein leider nicht
weil ich alles mögliche zu tun hatte und
es war mittagszeit
ich bin zufrieden
er sollte mir lächeln und fröhlich sein
manchmal ist es nicht einfach
[Musik]
in graubünden versucht ihren positiv zu
bleiben
trotz uneinigkeit mit ihrer tochter muss
sie auf kurs bleiben
der therapie sehr kritisch überleben
2016 war sehr sehr schwierige
bedingungen
und ja das natürlich kriegt und hätte
auch den kern hat eigentlich jedes jahr
so dass das man einfach dass er wirklich
völlig auf dem zahnfleisch laufen und
aber es ist ja nicht so dass es nach
michalsky und auf und ab geht s nimmer
so schnell
und jetzt zurück dann können sie auf 16
war ziemlich schwierig sich mit bio- und
zum teil vorschriften spritzigem hat
mercer so konventionell mit vielleicht
nun oder 88
der schwede meine frage ob sich das
gelohnt überhaupt und das überhaupt
notwendig ist
wahl von herrn harry potter reihe
miteinander willi diez anderem 17 oder
vorhandene arbeiten kann man anders
machen und jetzt mit dem sieht einfach
runder und sie machen
diese gab und so dass man so und so was
machen der familie entscheiden welche
firmen chefin und den betrieb übernehmen
spanierin alessandra oder mache so wie
sie will und darum januar zieht das ist
schon etwas ganz anderes wenn man dann
auch folgerichtig selber schafft es sich
beruhigen sie schön mannschaft vermied
also seiten sind so es geht ja gar keine
nachkommen
[Musik]
in bildung ist kein nachfolger in sicht
aber es gibt nach kommen denen marion
geheimrezepte weitergibt
das sind prozesse die stinken oder ein
bisschen ich finde nicht dass es stimmt
nicht sagt loos nie gesehen in der
schule nie gehört nein in der schule
nicht wenn es sein sind wie
sonnenstrahlen david in den mist
gemischt produzieren sie nicht nur
stickstoff und andere dinge
sie machen den mist auch intelligent
kapierst du dass die erde organisiert
sich selbst schon richtig ich bin die
großmutter die einfach weitermachen
hier kommen die brennesseln rein du
musst wissen daraus entwickelt sich ein
großartiger dünger
klar jede mutter oder großmutter träumt
davon ihre kinder und grosskinder
einzubinden
aber sie können frei entscheiden
es gibt sicher noch verrückter biaggi
und maria aber wo sind sie einen
zauberstab habe ich auch winter 2018
das neue jahr wird für die schweizer
winzer ein langes werden in genf für
tanja ein jahr der entscheidung
seit vier jahren ist das sehr schwierig
2013 haben wir durch einen hagelsturm am
20 juni 80 prozent der ernte verloren
das war eine schwere last es hat
wehgetan und tut jedes mal wieder weh
wenn man daran denkt wir waren in den
reben und sahen den sturm aufziehen wir
konnten nur noch ins auto steigen um zu
schauen wie die reben zerfetzt wurde
es war eine katastrophe
und da frau ist im jahr 2017 war eine
ähnliche katastrophe
es war schrecklich
[Musik]
du weißt es willkommen und kann es
nichts dagegen tun
nur warten beten kerzen anzünden oder
irgendwie die götter beschwören stehst
du nach der offensiv deshalb - 2 -3 grad
und du weißt alles ist futsch du erlebst
es live man sitzt echt wie oft nadeln
natürlich wenn es eintrifft dann ist man
versichert sogar gut versichert aber man
hofft ja auch nicht darauf dass das haus
abbrennt oder waren jeden tag einen
autounfall hat nur weil man dagegen
versichert ist und außerdem hat er ja
noch die kleinen zwillinge da muss man
schon aufpassen nicht alles zu verdienen
ein schlechter tag heute
so weg mit den tränen weg mit dem kummer
wie groß du bist geht es jetzt besser
2016 war ein großartiges jahr sehr gute
qualität schöner ertrag mit dem wir auch
ein gutes geschäft machen können aber
man bekommt nichts geschenkt ich bin
also geneigt zu sagen packen wir 2018 an
und vergessen wir nicht was wir uns
[Musik]
war
der frühling beginnt
da mir hat das wetter immer im auge nur
ein paar meter entfernt steht das jahr
auf messers schneide
im frühling geht es um den schutz der
knospen und damit der zukunft einige
kämpfen auf biodynamischen weg ein
zaubertrank beton liegt allein in den
händen von marion und dort der pfeiler
an dem dax einen unfall jünger schicksal
akzeptieren es hätte auch anderswo
passieren können und sich dauernd
anpassen
darum geht es im weinbau überall in den
rebbergen der schweiz beginnt eine neue
jahreszeit in der alles möglich ist
[Musik]
die fed definierung auf sf mit dieser
suite und leo p